moins cher garantie de sociabilité pour
l'enfant l'accueil en crèche fait partie
des modes de garde plébiscité par les
parents mais aujourd'hui seuls 18% des
moins de 3 ans bénéficient d'un accueil
dans ces structures
les places ils sont très chers et
c'était déjà le cas dans les années 90
exemple ici à marseille dans cette
crèche collective 2e arrondissement on
compte environ 80 bambins accueillis en
permanence et au moins autant d'inscrits
sur listes d'attentes
une situation qui n'a rien
d'exceptionnel à marseille pour bien des
parents trouver une place dans une
crèche sa part en un véritable parcours
du combattant
un parcours du combattant qui concerne
principalement les villes avec une forte
démographie en 1994 pour cet élu
parisien les évolutions de la société
expliquait aussi cette pénurie de places
dont sont victimes de notre succès les
crèches de la ville de paris vous avez
pu voir en venant ici sont des crèches
de qualité puis la deuxième raison c'est
très certainement l'augmentation du taux
d'activité féminin et peut être aussi
l'augmentation du nombre de familles
monoparentales à paris l'autre réalité
c'est aussi que les crèches coûte cher
aux municipalités qui hésitent à
investir dans de nouveaux locaux en 2000
face à ce constat le gouvernement de
lionel jospin donner un coup de pouce
aux communes le gouvernement a donc
décidé de débloquer un milliard et demi
de francs pour inciter les communes à
ouvrir plus de crèches et assouplir les
horaires d'ouverture et de fermeture
l'objectif fixé est d'accueillir 30 à
40000 bamba en plus malgré ces mesures
gouvernementales les places en crèche
continue de manquer en france
cette femme y était confronté en 2003
elle jongler avec son travail et la
garde de son enfant
tanger pas résolu le problème de garde
deux victoires je suis obligé de me
débrouiller
pour pallier à cette pénurie de places
dans les crèches municipales d'autres
initiatives se développent parmi elles
les crèches parentales gérés par des
associations de parents mais aussi les
crèches privées
grâce à ces dernières par exemple les
villes peuvent élargir leur offre
d'accueil dans cette crèche par exemple
la mairie a acheté une vingtaine des 40
places disponibles entre sept et dix
mille euros la place pour un an
les vingt autres places sont les
entreprises ne paient pas de commission
c'est les entreprises qui achètent un
berceau de verso de faso pour leurs
salariés
des alternatives qui ne suffisent pas à
satisfaire complètement la demande en
2018 un rapport du haut conseil à la
famille et à l'âge estimait qu'en france
il manquait encore cinq cent mille
places d'accueil pour les enfants de
moins de 3 ans
[Musique]